pendant toute la campagne des élections
législatives tv 60,18 vous aide à y voir
plus clair sur ce scrutin des 12 et 19
juin focus aujourd'hui sur la troisième
circonscription des yvelines avec justin
brasier bonsoir de la rédaction de tv 78
une troisième circonscription qui
regroupe 12 communes exactement alors
elle est située à l'est du département
est la troisième circonscription des
yvelines s'étend donc du chéné
rocancourt jusqu à feucherolles je vais
pas vous citer toutes les communes
puisque comme vous l'avez dit à grégory
lui en a 12 mai on retrouve par exemple
bougival à la celle-saint-cloud les
clayes-sous-bois saint nom la bretèche
ou encore villepreux elle regroupe
environ 115 mille habitants des villes
largement remporté par emmanuel macron à
l'élection présidentielle 2022 il
obtient plus de 40% des votes au premier
tour et plus de 70% dans presque toutes
ces villes au deuxième tour et si on
regarde l'historique sur ce territoire
on est plutôt ancré centre droit oui
depuis un bon moment parce que si on
repart en 2002 c'est anne marie idrac
qui l'emportent elles représentante de
l'union pour la démocratie française
donc partis de droite et du centre en
2007 elle c'est christian blanc qui est
élu dès le premier tour lui pour l'ump
toujours pour l'ump henri guaino en 2012
et telus et puis en 2010 est donc c'est
béatrice piron chefs d'entreprise et
nouvelle venue donc dans le monde
politique qui remporte la 6e la
circonscription pour la république en
marché deux fois si elle est élue au
second tour avec 58 93 % des votes elle
faisait face à l'époque à philippe
brillault pour les républicains qui
était alors maire du chesnay et cette
année pour cette nouvelle élection
béatrice pire on brigue un nouveau
mandat ah oui la députée sortante a
déposé sa candidature et se représente
aux élections législatives pour la même
circonscription
candidat de la majorité présidentielle
elle se présente cette fois ci pour la
bannière ensemble donc qui regroupe six
partis politiques dont la république en
marche devenu renaissance le modem et
horizons et c'est officiel depuis nous
avons reçu la liste définitive
aujourd'hui lui aura dit candidat dans
cette circonscription sûre au total dix
candidats exactement liste officielle
parmi les autres candidats on retrouve
bertrand coquard adjoint au maire à des
clefs sous bois candidats de la droite
et du centre ils représentent les
républicains et lui dit appeler après
rappelons le un faible score obtenu à la
présidentielle pour le parti et même au
niveau national et même au sein du
département il est soutenu par sébastien
demers ancien maire-adjoint de philippe
brillault aux chaînés rocancourt après
avoir annoncé sa candidature celui ci
s'est retirée pour appeler à se
rassembler donc derrière bertrand
coquard louise brody elle sera là
représentants de la coalition nubes donc
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale elle fait partie des huit
candidats de la france insoumise investi
par la coalition à savoir pardon au
premier tour de la présidentielle
jean-luc mélenchon avait obtenu environ
20% des votes dans trois communes donc
de cette circonscription est les
clayes-sous-bois villepreux et la celle
saint cloud et puis pour le reste des
candidats pierre yves painchaud
conseiller municipal de
mézières-sur-seine fait campagne pour le
rassemblement national jean-françois à
cuisnier représentera le nouveau parti
donc reconquête olivier augustin ouvrier
dans l'automobile se présente pour la
lutte ouvrière et puis lionel deschamps
pour le parti animalistes merci justin
m'en rappelle les dates des élections
législatives les 12 et 19 juin prochains